who do you think the strongest character
is
in the video games and who do you think
is the strongest character in the movie
well in a video game obviously the
coolest
and the most deadly is noob saibot
well a lot of people are going to
challenge that i know but in my opinion
yes
and in the game sub-zero i know i'm
being biased but
he's i think in the movie he's just
almost unbeatable
he's crazy um he he's kind of he's kind
of strong in the movie i'll say kind
yeah yeah yeah he's strong um
yeah of course i'm i'm being biased so
don't blame me
you might not be wrong though um so uh
this is uh
joking around a little bit um did you
ever it's not in the movie but did you
ever discuss
on set what your character's friendship
would be
friendship yeah the fatality friendship
yeah uh yeah we didn't discuss about
that because we
didn't plan it but i think
you know my kind of friendship sub-zero
behind kind of friendship probably like
exactly the same like in the game i'm
probably just gonna order like ice cream
truck and then let everybody enjoy the
ice cream you know for free
like it's on the house
who do you think is the uh the most
brutal fatality in the video game
and who do you think is the most brutal
kill
who what do you think is the most brutal
kill in the movie
i think the brutal and the fatality in
my answer
is the same move i think noob cyborg
sending his pantheon his specter inside
some inside the opponent's body
and just destroy it from inside that's
so brutal
that's the best fatality in the game
so in the movie there's a lot of vicious
death
there's a lot of vicious scenes what do
you think is the one that fans in the
theater are just going to go
what you know and freak out on i have my
answer you know i
love that part kung lao
when he's riding nightera and then you
know
put his hat like a chainsaw on the
ground and then just fly the chainsaw
and like
split the body open that's the best
i love that one
um do you think uh a lot of people who
are going to watch the movie i think
they like learning like behind the
scenes facts
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the actual making of the
movie
a fact of the movie that i could not
move or walk the first time i fit the
costume because it was super heavy and
stiff
so we worked a lot in a process to you
know
make it you know adjustable for me to be
able to fight
so it was it was so funny you know i
looked myself in the mirror like i
am sub-zero it was i was so confident
but when i was when i tried to
move oh i couldn't move because it just
it's just so heavy and stiff so that's
probably a funny one
you know i actually that was something
that i didn't even realize but i spoke
to some of the other actors and they
talked about how
they're really good at martial arts and
they're really good at doing things
but the costume made it really hard to
pull off circuits yeah
yeah i think i think that's this problem
not just more
for motor combat you know in all
superhero movies
the costume needs to look amazing like
great materials
but at the same time we both know what
looks
good in in our eyes it's not going to be
look it's not going to be great for the
performer
so that but we i think we got so lucky
we
we we have uh carrie um cappy because
kathy
she's just non-stop you know adjusting
non-stop you know he's
her team just don't stop adjusting parts
so we can move you know
kung lao me luiz he's just like oh you
cannot move your hand and
someone is just like doing this crazy
stuff and then chop it here and then
stretch it
so without her
it's impossible to perform those fights
so i gotta give it to her
on that note i need to stop and as i
said i thought you did a great job in
the movie and i thank you
thank you i hope it's a huge hit you
guys can make a sequel
thank you fingers crossed